c'est un tabou depuis liberty sim
affaires sociales à partir là oui c'est
moi
j'ai oublié les capotes et quoi
[Musique]
parce que je vais te dire qui est entré
dans mon bureau pas plus tard que hier
vanessa bestel insight
vanessa pestel avec ses miches à un
million de dollars la plus belle
gonzesse qu'on ait connu toi et moi y'a
du monde ou quoi le truc qui n'existe
pas la main fallait aussi belle qu'elle
est brillante m'a jamais calculé au
collège maintenant elle m'appelle toutes
les dix minutes
mais c'est peut-être un signe aux arêtes
ya pas de signe tu avec juliette celle
d'un must
cette complémentaire un fou au fait la
moue cela je vois tes couilles
[Musique]
absolument que la baise basket foot de
juliette
[Musique]
on est potes je veux pas qu'on soit
génie on dit qu'on est potes et on s'en
bat ne s'est pas non plus le meilleur
moyen de potes
je sens des perturbé
je suis venu dire c'est une idée à la
con moi d'abord tu laquelle et apprête à
la prise de conscience
ça fais ton couloir cesser mon couloir
hockey la nature puisse encore dans
l'eau je te jugent trop cool je le sens
tout réchauffé là